auch sie christiane h sie ist eine der
opfer von abdirahman york getötet weil
sie ihr kind ihre tochter geschützt hat
in diesem kaufhaus woolworth hat sie
sich auf sie gestürzt und ist dabei
selbst erstochen worden
heute ist ein tag der trauer bundesweit
für diese opfer von würzburg aber es ist
auch ein tag vieler offener fragen über
diesen fall
über diese bluttat von würzburg müssen
wir sprechen jetzt die richtigen fragen
bei bild ja wir kommen an diesem
sonntagabend dieses messer massaker von
würzburg das wird uns auch zwei tage
danach noch auf und das ist das
protokoll dieser tat es dauert nur
sieben minuten sieben minuten in denen
er eine blutspur durch würzburg zieht
abdirahman j 24 jahre alt aus somalia
getötet drei frauen und verletzt sechs
weitere
freitag 17 uhr ab dieser mann betritt
diese woolworth filiale in der
würzburger innenstadt der somalia fragt
eine verkäuferin wo sind die messer dann
greift er nach dem mit der längsten
klinge 13 cm und sticht auf die
verkäuferin ein
gezielt in nacken und hals direkt danach
auf zwei weitere kunden eine 80 jahre
alte rentnerin und eine 24 jahre alte
mutter
alle drei starben noch am tatort
laut augenzeugen unter dem alu akbar ruf
des täters 17 uhr 4
die ersten notrufe gehen bei der polizei
der messe killer rennt auf die straße
barfuß in richtung einer
sparkassenfiliale dort sticht auf eine
73 jahre alte frau ein dutzend mal 17
uhr sechs eine gruppe mutiger männer
versucht den täter unter kontrolle zu
bringen
in angst selbst zum opfer zu werden
[Applaus]
mit regenschirmen stöcken und
gartenstühlen versuchen sie den killer
zu stoppen
auch er stellt sich dem mann jetzt in
den weg bei einer der helden von
würzburg
17 07 auch die polizei ist nun vor ort
als der killer sich mit dem messer auf
die beamten zu bewegt schießt einer der
polizisten abdirahman j in den
oberschenkel durchschuss der 24 jahre
alte killer ist festgenommen
das blutbad von würzburg hat endlich ein
ende nach sieben schrecklichen minuten
und über diese sieben blutigen momente
minuten wollen wir sprechen jetzt mit
menschen die diese minuten erlebt haben
nämlich die arabi den sie gerade schon
gesehen haben als allen dieser helden
von würzburg wir sprechen auch darüber
mit christian markus der als notarzt am
tatort war und geholfen hat mit elvis
tick der ebenfalls eingeschritten ist
geholfen hat und jetzt auch dort ganz in
der nähe des tatortes steht und mit dem
bayerischen innenminister joachim
herrmann ihnen allen schönen guten abend
der hermann wo waren sie an diesem abend
als die notrufe eingingen wo sie war
vermutlich sehr schnell auch von
informiert wurden von dieser tat wo
waren sie zu dem zeitpunkt war ich in
meinem abgeordnetenbüro hier in erlangen
indem ich jetzt gerade auch wie das ist
und zu wien zugeschaltet bin mich an
dann hier die informationen aus dem
innenministerium aus dem lagezentrum und
der polizeiführung
erreichte dann die schrecklichen
meldungen
kurz darauf dass es drei tote gibt
schwerverletzten und daraufhin habe ich
mich dann entschlossen auch sofort nach
würzburg zu fahren
das haben sie dann sofort gemacht was
ich ihn in den ersten momenten dort den
menschen joachim herrmann durch den kopf
gegangen
zum einen natürlich ein entsetzen
darüber dass es in solchen anschlag gibt
in dem moment wusste ich noch nicht wie
die weiteren hintergründe sind es
geisterten dann ja schon die ersten
videos im netz
aber natürlich auch und das habe ich
dann bei vielen weiteren gesprächen an
dem abend immer wieder ist mir das
begegnen gesprächen polizisten und auch
mit rettungskräften die erinnerung an
den schrecklichen anschlag vor fünf
jahren ist sich in wenigen tagen zum
fünften mal das ist ja damals diesen
islamistischen anschlag in den zug bei
heidingsfeld b in würzburg gegeben hat
wo eine islamistische attentäter mit
einer axt im zug menschen schwerst
verletzt hat gestern außerhalb des zuges
von mitgliedern des
spezialeinsatzkommandos gestoppt worden
und auch in notwehr erschossen worden
vielen ist diese schreckliche tat von
vor fünf jahren noch in lebhafter
erinnerung trauer und sofort war das
gefühl da ist hier wieder so etwas
passiert ja oberbürgermeister von
würzburg herrmann hat an dem abend eine
offene brief geschrieben und hat gesagt
er hat geweint an diesem abend aber auch
sie tränen in den augen gehabt an diesem
abend oder morgen danach
ja ich habe das bei den besuchen vor ort
in derart unmittelbar auch so gespürt
die drei toten frauen im woolworth auch
die persönliche begegnung mit zum
beispiel notärzten und
rettungssanitätern dort vor abholung
gespürt hat die haben ja jeden tag mit
leid und unglück zu tun aber solch
brutale
schwerste verletzungen diese
messerstecherei das was sie dort
vorgefunden haben da hat man gespürt
dass auch an den eingesetzten polizisten
und rettungskräften nicht spurlos
vorüber gegangen ist sondern das ja auch
man hier vielleicht ich bin kein
psychologe traumatisiert waren also sie
uns mit design rechnen haben heimlich
schrecklich lassen sie uns mit einem
sprechen der dort zu den einsatzkräften
zählte mit nämlich dr christian markus
seit 20 jahren als notarzt im einsatz
vom universitätsklinikum dort in
würzburg herr markus was war das erste
bild sie sind dorthin gerufen worden
dann innerhalb von minuten dort am
tatort angekommen und was haben sie als
erstes vorgefunden
nun soll ein stichwort hat man natürlich
auch als professioneller wetter erstmal
angst und muss schauen ist die lage dort
sicher und dank der zivilen couragierten
eingreifens der würzburger mitbürger und
dem beherzten zu fassen der würzburger
polizei war für uns die lage relativ
schnell sicher so dass wir uns den
verletzten und den weiteren betroffenen
zu wenden konnten die einsatzstelle ist
relativ übersichtlich auch wenn es
insgesamt mehrere tatorte waren und
mehrere einsatzstellen arbeiter dieses
chaos und diese bestimmung dieser
ratlosigkeit das hat eine ganz andere
güte eine ganz andere qualität als wenn
man zum beispiel zu einer unfallstelle
alt die ganze einsatzstelle hat diese
geschichte in den tiefen gezeichnet in
die gesichter aller betroffenen
und wir alle müssen dankbar sein das
erste bürger gab und dass unsere
polizeikräfte nur stark und zu schnell
vor ort wo haben sie ganz konkret die
verletzten versorgt waren sie in dieser
woolworth filiale
drinnen im einsatz davor vor der
sparkasse haben sie mit den
schwerstverletzten sprechen können also
für mich sind bleiben die szenen ich war
ungefähr an jeder einsatzstelle
zumindest kurz und mehr im überblick zu
verschaffen
in so einer solchen situation ins
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben und so hat die
leitstelle alarmierte eine
sanitätseinsatzleitung für den
rettungsdienstlichen einsatz zu
formieren
der leitende notarzt dr trauen da unser
torische leiter kienzle und die lage
sehr gut im griff und haben die nach
treffenden einsatzkräfte dann auch die
jeweiligen patienten verteilen können
und das ist natürlich eine situation wo
jeder da hilft indem wasser gut ist
alles besitzt kann und narkose machen
ich habe aber auch bilder gesehen eines
nieder belasten änderung der also mit
bloßen händen vor der filiale blutung
gestillt hat und sie haben es gut
angesprochen
in unserer situation in seiner solchen
situation des menschlichkeit die beste
waffe gegen gewalt und ich glaube dass
die persönliche zuwendung ich hoffe dass
unsere verunfallten verletzten beinahe
getöteten viel davon mitgenommen haben
dass wir diesen zuspruch schal an der
einsatzstelle versucht haben zu bieten
haben sie menschenleben retten können
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wovon gehen sie
aus also die neuesten meldungen auch der
polizei und darauf möchte ich hier gerne
auch stützen sind so dass die vierte
person die auch an die uniklinik
würzburg gegangen ist mittlerweile nicht
mehr in lebensgefahr schwebt dass die
ersten patienten aus dem krankenhaus
entlassen sind
das macht diejenigen die vor ort getötet
wurden und zwar mit furchtbarer
brutalität getötet worden sind nicht
lebendig und deshalb sollten wir ganz
deutschland unter liebenden und auch in
die toten denken
das tun wir uns in gleichermaßen dankbar
für ihren einsatz dort der ein
beruflicher war aber eher wichtig und
die arabi
die waren dort ganz unvermittelt
würzburger innenstadt tätig was wollten
sie eigentlich machen am freitagabend
ersten abend und zwar folgendes die
wolken zum friseur geleitet welche und
zwei kollegen die man gebündelt und
sieht allerdings wird dieser nicht da
darauf finden sind wir dann in die
sparkasse liedern und all so aus als
dass stockers raushaben hat das ist
überhaupt gespielt werden sie für uns
angefangen
wir sehen genau diese szenen und sehen
sie auch hier laufen denn im schwarzen
pullover sehen sie herr dick das ist
eben in der nähe dieser
sparkassenfiliale das sind die momente
in dem sie auf den täter treffen ihn
sehen direkt vor ihnen läuft er in
diesem beigen pullover und barfuß warum
sind sie nicht weggelaufen in dem moment
bei vielen wäre dass der impuls gewesen
möglicherweise bei mir auch so schnell
wie möglich weg ich kann es nicht genau
beschreiben aber sie müssen sich
vorstellen ich glaube dass sparkasse
raus sie passiert sehen wir die menschen
in panik geraten die leute anfangen zu
schreien zu weinen nicht wissen was sie
tun sollen einfach todesangst haben die
hat sich auch in diesem land muss
ehrlich sagen ich glaube zwei verlauf
allerdings habe ich begriffen dass das
einmal nicht aufstellen will wir müssen
stoppen hingegangen sind sogar in dem
moment um das zu unterbinden um
einzugreifen
haben sie dem täter in diesen momenten
in die augen direkt in die augen schauen
kann
es gab einen moment wie geplant ist auch
in meine kollegen umkreis haben
umzingelt und dann stand ich vielleicht
eineinhalb meter oder zwei hinter ihm
und habe versucht von hinten dann in
wien anzugleichen
ich hatte auch eine flasche in der hand
und wollte irgendwie den kopf schweißen
und dann wie gesagt einfach zu verfügen
um des rechtsstaates zu bekommen und
dann fixiert ist im stift es hat leider
nicht geklappt jetzt umgedreht folgt
einem samba und in diesem moment stand
gibt es auch genau die es sonst
vielleicht ein halb zehn tagen gesagt er
wusste von mir das remis wenn es sein
muss
wirklich ein stopp mit ermittelt und
surfen was haben sie in dem moment
gedacht also was hat ihnen dieser blick
gesagt die musiker die hilfe sterben um
welches stück möglich ist so einfach wie
woche mit jungs los ich habe es nicht
gesehen dass das ist einleuchtend oder
oder das drängt es ist angerichtet
so war es nicht wir sehen diese szenen
noch mal gedreht mit der handy kamera
eines thera die dort eben ganz in ihrer
nähe in der würzburger innenstadt waren
ich möchte jetzt auch sprechen mit
therapie der seit rund einem jahr in
deutschland ist der schon recht gut
deutsch spricht aber in dieser sendung
gerne noch einmal übersetzt werden
möchte auf von persisch das machen wir
gerne auch sie waren in der würzburger
innenstadt therapie an diesem abend sind
spazieren gegangen dort und treffen dort
ebenfalls dann auf diesen täter was
haben sie in den ersten momenten gedacht
als sie sehen da läuft plötzlich ein
mann mit einem großen messer durch die
stadt und sticht leute ab frauen ab
persönlich habe ich hab's mir das angst
gehabt als ich da habe ich meine angst
verloren und dann habe ich nur gedacht
dass ich ihn stoppen muss ich versuchen
muss dass er nicht weitere menschen
töten kann
das war mein gefühl ein anderes gefühl
hatte ich nicht hier sehen sie auf
diesen videos wie sie wirklich direkt
auge in auge gegenüberstehen und sich
ihm entgegenstellen dass er eben nicht
sich noch mehr opfer suchen kann in den
momenten das war aber doch gefährlich
für sie rabbi
ich habe ein leben augen nicht anders
gedacht ich habe nur daran gedacht als
ich in die stoffe augen nicht mehr
menschen getötet werden ich habe gesagt
dass ich vielleicht ihn stoppen
ein anderer in die stopfen aber ich
dachte ich könnte das ich habe ich bin
auch gerutscht und bin zu boden gefallen
dass er die regeln nötig geworden und
habe ich habe ich habe dann versucht
wieder auf die beine kommt damit auf den
fans kann man diese szene nicht sehen
leider viele aufnahmen die man sieht die
schläge die ich schon verpasst habe und
auch die versuche unternommen
ich wollte ihm das messer abnehmen aber
das ist mir nicht gelungen
leider hat der täter dieser 24-jährige
somalia irgendwas zu ihm gesagt
irgendwas gerufen gebrüllt nein
überhaupt nicht
nein er hat nichts gesagt er hat keinen
laut von sich gegeben
er hat ja auch eine maske getragen
dass er das irgendwie vielleicht etwas
getrunken hat er alkohol und so das kann
ich auch nicht sagen ich kann nicht
sagen in welchem zustand sich befand ich
habe nur gesehen dass er schuldlose
menschen die unschuldige menschen
getötet hat und jeden der eine traf
hatte hat er mit messer verletzt und
diese stehlen konnte ich nicht ertragen
ich wollte etwas tun ihn stoppen konnte
[Musik]
das wissen wir heute dass sie
tatsächlich sie beide dazu beigetragen
haben dass sich der täter nicht nur mehr
nicht noch mehr opfer suchen konnte in
der zeit und dass er dann wenige minuten
später eben nach ihrem beherzten
einschreiten auch festgenommen werden
konnte auch mithilfe natürlich der
polizeibeamten und einem ganz gezielten
schuss in den oberschenkel
herrmann bayerischer innenminister wenn
sie die beiden hören und auch den nord
notarzt herrn markus sind das helden für
sie ganz klar ja das sind echte helden
es war ein großartiger einsatz wir haben
gerade auch in der gedenk vereine drauf
im kiliansdom in würzburg
genau darüber gesprochen unser
ministerpräsident hat sich für dieses
großartige engagement ausdrücklich
bedanken ebenso der würzburger
oberbürgermeister und ministerpräsident
würde würde auch überlegen inwieweit
eben die menschen die so geholfen haben
wie wir das gerade hier gesehen und
gehört haben hier besonders geehrt
werden in allernächster zeit für dieses
couragierte eintreten wie könnte das
aussehen überlegt werden zum beispiel es
gibt eine bayerische rettungsmedaille
für menschen die um das scheint mir
jedoch der fall zu sein ihr eigenes
leben aufs spiel setzten um andere
menschen lebend zu retten
das muss jetzt noch mal angeschaut
werden aber ich meine wirklich das ist
ein sehr couragiertes ein heldenhaftes
verhalten und auch die polizei sagte
damit sind zumindest noch mal in der
gesamten zeitlichen ablauf wie sie den
dargestellt haben vielleicht die
entscheidende minute nochmal diese täter
hingehalten worden bis dann wirklich der
erste polizeibeamte vor ort eintraf und
mit seiner schusswaffe den täter
endgültig stoppen konnte sonst wäre
womöglich in dieser minute plus minus um
die es geht schon wieder weitere
menschen diesem täter zum opfer gefallen
insofern spricht wirklich alles dafür
dass diese menschen mit ihren
heldenhaften eintreten anderen menschen
das leben gerettet haben
herr markus lassen sie uns über das
sprechen was für sie von diesem blutigen
freitagabend bleibt dann weiß sie aus
eigener erfahrung früher bin
rettungssanitäter gewesen bei weitem
nicht so lange im rettungswagen gefahren
wie sie aber doch bleiben aus dieser
zeit bilder im kopf was glauben sie
welche bilder bei ihnen bleiben
vielleicht schlechte träume sogar von
der freitagnacht vom freitagabend in
würzburg und das wird zweifelsohne so
sein dass auch uns schlechte bilder in
den nächten erhöht werden
aber es gehört auch zu unsere
professionalität damit umzugehen und ich
denke noch mehr als an uns
professionelle rettungskräfte die zu
unserer professionalität zählen dass wir
uns öffnen unseren kollegen dass wir das
gespräch suchen dass wenn wir
pathologien krankheitszeichen an uns
selber entdecken dass wir und dann in
hilfe an hilfe anbieter wenden werden
ich hätte noch einen aufruf an alle
diejenigen die als passanten dabei waren
und viele von dem habe ich irgendwie so
aus dem hintergrund gehört die also
geschichten erzählt haben dass verletzte
die vor dem der filiale dieses einkaufs
hauses zum beispiel verletzt wurden
sich schützend vor kinder oder frauen
gestellt haben dass es menschen gab die
kinder und jugendliche gesammelt haben
sollen sie in anführungsstrichen an die
hand genommen haben verjagt haben von
der gefahrenstelle
das sind auch helden neben den beiden
die sich hier vorstellen
das sind die helden die jetzt hier nicht
im fernsehen zu sehen sind und ich
glaube wir sollten auch an die denken
wir haben sicherlich auch schweres
ertragen
aber wir haben eine kleine rüstungen
dass es unser büro wir müssen uns damit
tagtäglich beschäftigen
und wir haben auch infrastrukturen auf
die wir jederzeit zurückkommen können
wenn es uns schlecht geht
das ist auch profi sein und trotzdem
schüttelt man das natürlich nicht ganz
leicht ab genau wie sie es sagen dr
markus dick sie haben gerade uns
geschildert wie sie den täter auch
erlebt haben wie sie ihm für momente
auch in die augen blicken mussten nun
wissen wir mittlerweile er war zweimal
bereits in der psychiatrie an mal ein
bisschen länger einmal für einen tag und
beim letzten besuch hieß es kein
behandlungsbedarf wie viel verständnis
haben sie im nachhinein für so etwas
naja ich muss ehrlich sagen wenn die
erste und schlugen dort wortmann es gibt
wir haben uns darauf den hat denke ich
mal
allerdings bin ich der meinung man
müsste ihm das anderes sich ein
verlassen und etwas anderes finden womit
man solche heute ludwig präventiv für
stop es noch ist ja dass er lügt die
erst vor einem tag behandlung war da und
hat das geschehen wir müssen versuchen
in zukunft einfacher zu handeln
darüber werden wir gleich hier in der
runde diskutieren letzte frage an herrn
rabbi sie sind selbst noch nicht allzu
lange in deutschland rund ein jahr habe
ich gerade schon gesagt jetzt ist es ein
flüchtling der aus somalia kommt der
hier subsidiären schutz bekommt seit
sechs jahren hier lebt nicht integriert
ist und wohl zunehmend offenbar ja
keinen sinn darin sieht hier zu leben
nach einem messer sucht und dann drei
frauen ersticht in deutschland wie
wütend macht sie selber noch nicht lange
in deutschland eine solche tat
ich will sehr traurig ich bin auch jetzt
noch traurig war auch 1000 jetzt traurig
weil er weiter auch ein migrant war
gekommen war und ich bin auch froh
darüber dass ich auch ein migrant innen
und in deutschland sind und ihn
angreifen konnte und ihn stoppen konnte
und ich kann ich möchte auch den
menschen hier in deutschland sagen dass
nicht eine migranten so sind die wie der
mann mit dem präsidenten und andere sind
auch wenn ich ihn wahrscheinlich nicht
als helden bezeichnet
ich habe ich habe das aus aus dem
inneren aus innere überzogen wird aus
von militärs grunde gemacht und
viele sehen die für und viele haben
angst gehabt aber ich bin nach vorlegen
und ich habe mein leben in gefahr
gebracht weil wegen der menschen die in
diesem land leben hier zuflucht gewährt
haben
und ich habe nur das getan ich bitte sie
mich nicht als helfen wird zu bezeichnen
ich habe nicht gesagt ich hatte es war
nur eine humanitäre handlung das war
meine jung meine meine pflicht ich bin
auch sehr froh dass ich ihn ein bisschen
daran hindern konnte und wie noch
traurig darüber dass ich nicht früher da
war um ihn gänzlich stoppen und
vielleicht hätte ich dazu beitragen
können das vielleicht nur eine person
getötet würde und deswegen bin ich auch
sehr traurig dass so viele menschen
getötet wurden
arabi an diesem tag an dem natürlich
weiter die trauer über wiegt dank ihn
trotzdem sehr für ihre bescheidenheit
für ihren großen einsatz der eben ja
gerade nicht selbstverständlich war und
für ihre gerade so bewegenden worte
danke dass sie heute hier noch einmal zu
gast waren bei bild live danke herrn
dicke und danke auch herrn markus für
ihre schilderung und ich wünsche ihnen
allen alles gute dass sie die bilder so
schnell wie möglich aus dem kopf
bekommen und ich bin schon glücklich sie
zumindest ein dicke und therapie wieder
draußen auf der straße zu sehen und
würzburg dort wo die tat passierte vor
zwei tagen und wo es jetzt wieder ganz
belebtes und wo der alltag dann eben
doch wieder anläuft ich danke ihnen für
das gespräch
herrmann ich würde gerne mit etwas
weiter machen worüber wir ja in den
vergangenen stunden viel gehört haben
sie sind das haben sie gerade auch
gesagt ja sofort zum tatort geeilt am
freitagabend und kann dann sehr schnell
auch über einige details über einige
hintergründe aufklären können sie hatten
relativ schnell schon relativ viele
informationen beisammen um 20 uhr oder
viertel nach acht als sie ihr statement
dort am tatort gemacht haben und dort
haben sie auch sofort zitiert dass
mehrere zeugen allahu akbar rufe gehört
haben wollten und sie haben das sofort
geschildert später kamen weitere
informationen über eis unterlagen die
man gefunden hat bei dem 24-jährigen
somalia haben wir es hier also mit einem
terror fall zu tun
das kann ich heute noch nicht
abschließend beurteilen aber ich habe
mich mit den eingesetzten polizeibeamten
vor ort der polizeiführung und auch der
staatsanwaltschaft abgesprochen und mit
einer solchen situation natürlich auch
aufgrund von verschiedenen erfahrungen
der letzten jahre schon wichtig wenn
etwas gesichert ist dann wollen wir es
auch der öffentlichkeit nicht
vorenthalten weil sonst sehr schnell
wieder vorwürfe laut werden da gibt es
auch dieses und jenes erkenntnisse warum
wird das nicht der öffentlichkeit gesagt
und nach dem ist wirklich verifiziert
war von mehreren seiten bestätigt dass
der täter am tatort allah akbar gerufen
hatte war ich mir dann einig mit den
genannten kollegen dann muss das auch
der öffentlichkeit gesagt werden
gleichzeitig haben wir diese information
über offensichtlich psychische störungen
und eine psychiatrische untersuchung und
dies alles muss man natürlich jetzt wie
ein großes puzzle zusammensetzen ich
kann heute noch nicht abschließend sagen
dazu sind die informationen einfach noch
zu gering
ist das wirklich ein islamistischer
terroranschlag ist die psychiatrische
störung im vordergrund verbindet sich
beide sind schrecklicher weise wie auch
immer all das muss jetzt sorgfältig
ermittelt werden aber klar ist
jedenfalls das was wir belastbar
vorliegt das muss der öffentlichkeit
auch mitgeteilt werden damit auch nicht
der eindruck entsteht als ob man dem
nicht nachgehen würde
sie haben diese frage ja gerade schon
auch in dem gespräch hier aufgeworfen
wir werden natürlich jetzt die
gelegenheit wenn am morgen wieder soweit
alle verschiedenen beteiligten
dienststellen vor dem betrieb sind die
ärzte da sind unsere natürlich die frage
nachgehen warum ist der nach nur einem
tag gibt's ja das tun wir gleich noch
mal lassen sie uns in den momentan
geschickt worden
das machen wir gleich noch mal das
vertiefen wir gleich lassen wir uns
einen moment bei der frage nach
terrorismus bleiben und dazu möchte ich
gerne holen peter neumann
sie kennen ihn alle als terror experten
vom king's college in london herzlichen
oder schönen guten abend herr neumann
wir sprechen über die frage wie viel
hinweise auf terror gibt es in dieser
tat weh mit welchen worten würden sie
das fasten auf diese frage war das
terrorist dieser 24-jähriger somalia für
sie ein terrorist also ich würde es auch
wenn ich nicht da wahrscheinlich
wiederhole ganz ähnlich beantworten wie
hermann ich glaube wir haben hier mit
zwei strängen zu tun
das eine ist der potenzielle
terroristische strang und da gibt es
einige hinweise
das zweite ist die psychische
anfälligkeit vorbelastung ich glaube wir
müssen noch viel mehr wissen darüber wie
schwer war diese psychische erkrankung
wie schwer war sie bei der vorbereitung
der tat und bei der tat selbst und was
für eine diagnose wurde da überhaupt
gestellt und inwiefern ist der täter
deshalb zurechnungsfähig gewesen oder
nicht wenn er zurechnungsfähig war und
auch das ist möglich wir haben in der
vergangenheit verschiedene
terroristische anschläge gehabt wo wir
täter hatten die psychische
anfälligkeiten hatten aber eben nicht so
schwer dass sie nicht zurechnungsfähig
gewesen wären ich denke wie gesagt wir
müssen da etwas geduld haben bis wir da
die meinung von experten haben die das
auch richtig einordnen können momentan
aufgrund der aktuell verfügbaren
informationen kann man das abschließend
leider noch nicht beurteilt die geduld
haben wir herrn neumann trotzdem die
wirkung dieser tat ist ja in jedem fall
eine terroristische also eine ganz stark
abschreckende angst machende absolut und
das ist auch der sinn und zweck von
terrorismus und deswegen zur mode oder
propaganda es genau solche taten auf und
wir haben auch in der vergangenheit
gesehen dass der irs ganz genau weiß
dass auch psychisch labile personen sich
von der propaganda des angezogen fühlen
und diese aufschnappen und dann mit
rhetorischen versatzstücken oder einer
nativen des er es dann solche taten
durchführen
das ist von ihr es so gewünscht das
bedeutet allerdings nicht dass der täter
dadurch motiviert war das müssen wir
jetzt beantworten aber absolut der ist
richtet sich mit seiner propaganda genau
an solche leute die möglicherweise ganz
andere probleme haben und die dann durch
diese propaganda einen weg finden
sozusagen eine eine eine ideologie oder
einer tief zu bekommen was ihnen mehr
mehr geltung und mehr bedeutung
ich fasse das noch mal kurz zusammen
herr herrmann wir haben jetzt einen
täter einen 24-jährigen somalia
der ruft bei der tat auch allahu akbar
der bedient sich möglicherweise in
seinem tatmuster anderen taten die er
auch so bereits gesehen hat von denen er
so bereits gehört hat man findet später
bei ihm unterlagen
von icis man weiß mittlerweile auch wie
er sich bei der tat verhalten hat und
möglicherweise ist die verbindung
zwischen einer psychischen störung und
einem terroristischen ideologen ja gar
nicht auch vorhanden sogar diese
verbindung das heißt warum sind wir da
so vorsichtig von terrorismus zu
sprechen warum gilt das in den ersten
stunden in den ersten tagen weitgehend
als tabu nein das gilt nicht als tabu
sondern ich habe ja als erster bereits
am freitag haben gesagt es spricht hier
einiges dafür dass es sich um
islamistischen terror handeln könnte
aber natürlich muss das alles sorgfältig
ermittelt werden
ja es gibt diesen hinweis der täter hat
wohl im laufe der folgenden stunden dann
wohl auch mal davon gesprochen dass
handelt es sich um seinen beitrag zum
dschihad
die polizei hat ja dann auch sofort
seinen wohnraum in der
obdachlosenunterkunft in der gelebt hat
durchsuchte hat hier auch wohl einiges
gefunden was auf ja islamistisches
propagandamaterial hinweisen könnte die
polizei hat zwei handys von ihm gefunden
die gegenwärtig ausgewertet werden das
ist das alles in fremdsprachen in
arabisch somalisch wie auch immer
entsprechend gefasst ist muss das
natürlich erst sorgfältig übersetzte
ausgewertet werden
aber all das geschieht im moment und ich
sage nochmal ja er spricht sehr viel
angesichts dessen was wir auf gefunden
haben dafür dass es sich um ein
islamistisch islamistisch motivierte tat
handeln könnte der verdacht ist eklatant
deswegen hat ja auch die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft münchen die in
bayern zentral für straftaten mit
potenziell terroristischem hintergrund
zuständig ist die leitung der gesamt
ermittlungen übernommen
ich fragte deswegen nach dem tabu nicht
wegen ihrer äußerungen hermann sondern
beispielsweise auch wegen eines
verbundes
die ehrung von regierungssprecher
steffen seibert der da sehr früh von
einem amokläufer gesprochen hat also da
gibt es keinen hinweis auf mögliche
terroristische hintergründe
da gibt es auch keinen hinweis auf die
herkunft des täters herr neumann finden
sie das verharmlosen oder auf eine
falsche spur leitend ein solcher
kommentar ja auch sehr sehr kurz nach
der tat
also ich denke es ist richtig dass man
wenn es ganz ganz kurz nach der tat ist
dass man vorsichtig sich äußert weil wir
natürlich auch wissen dass wenn eine tat
erst mal als terrorismus beschrieben
wird dass das eine gewisse dynamik
auslöst und dass das auch möglicherweise
in einigen situationen sich dann als
falsch heraus aber er ist ja verzeihen
sie herr neumann der steffen seibert ist
ja in dem moment nicht vorsichtig legt
sich ja fest auf namoc lauf naja es war
ja in gewisser hinsicht auch ein
amoklauf es kann ein terroristischer
amoklauf gewesen sein da ablauf
beschreibt die taktik die verwendet
wurde aber nicht den nicht unbedingt den
hintergrund und deswegen bin ich das
nicht unbedingt falsch dass sozusagen
natürlich kann man dann auch noch etwas
hinterher schicken und später dann
qualifizieren und sagen wir gehen davon
aus dass das mit islamistisch motiviert
war aber in einer solchen frühen
situation sich nicht vollständig
festlegen zu wollen wenn er gesagt hätte
es ist ein islamistischer terroranschlag
dann wäre das meiner meinung nach noch
unvorsichtiger gewesen als das was da
als street veröffentlicht es blendet nur
alles aus dass beendet das außer hermann
was sie dann am tatort sehr früh auch
sagen konnten sie hatten ja diese
informationen und sind sind ja auch
nicht übers ziel hinausgeschossen und
haben genau so wie sie es jetzt auch
nicht machen ganz klar von einem
terroranschlag gesprochen sondern sie
haben ganz sauber die hinweise genannt
die bei ihnen auf dem tisch lagen und
gleichzeitig hat man eben bei ganz
vielen gesehen es wurde was ausgeblendet
man wollte diese verbindung offenbar
nicht herstellen man hat ganz bewusst
von einem amoklauf gesprochen
ich weiß nicht was hier den ein oder
anderen zu seinen äußerungen motiviert
hat aber meine linie ist so schrecklich
jedes dieser eigenes schon seitdem ich
im minister bin ja man muss sich mit
bedacht äußern dann muss jeweils genau
überlegen vor allen dingen in welchen
punkten sind wir uns sicher was sind
fakten
wo sind dinge im moment noch eher
spekulativ aber meine linie ist seit
jeher das was einmal sehr sicher ist
nach den feststellungen der polizei nach
aussagen von zeugen
das war sehr sicher ist darauf hat in
der regel die öffentlichkeit auch einen
anspruch zu erfahren und schießen dann
er auch die spekulationen und zum teil
dann auch falsche gerüchte ins kraut
wenn ich das was ich weiß nicht
von seiten der behörden der
öffentlichkeit sage das ist manchmal
eine gratwanderung aber ich glaube es
ist wichtig in solchen situationen dass
die menschen auch spüren dass wir
einerseits sagen was wir noch nicht
wissen was unklar ist aber dass wir das
wo wir heute schon relativ sicher sind
dass wir dieses auch in der
öffentlichkeit gegebenenfalls mit ein
paar vorbehalten bin benennen
und darum geht es ja auch was mir auch
wichtig ist wenn ich das noch hinzufügen
darf
wichtig ist dass wir da auch nicht
wieder gegensätze konnte entsprechend
konstruieren
das schließt sich nämlich auch nicht aus
dass der psychiatrische probleme gehabt
haben kann das muss jetzt auch in den
nächsten tagen mit den behandelnden
ärzten noch mal geklärt werden und auf
der anderen seite aber trotzdem
vielleicht eine islamistische gesinnung
hatte wir haben diese aus meiner sicht
extrem leidige diskussion auch vor fünf
jahren bei diesem amoklauf im münchner
olympia einkaufszentrum gehabt wo sich
dann herausstellte dass der täter auch
schon eine weile sehr rassistischen
grundüberzeugungen zum beispiel
gegenüber türkischstämmigen mitbürgern
anhing
und dann ging ein elender streit darum
ob der jetzt mehr psychiatrische
probleme weil er auch gemobbt wurde und
weil er offensichtlich autistische
veranlagung hatte ob das jetzt mehr das
eine und das andere war es liegt eben in
der ja letztendlich besonderen
persönlichkeitsstruktur mancher menschen
dass dies beides dann zusammen trifft da
kann ganz sicher seine verrückten
geschichten mit psychischen problemen
verrückt und islam ist schließt sich
nicht aus ganz im gegenteil
möglicherweise schauen wir einmal wagte
des täters hinein
die akte des messer killers von würzburg
ab der armani und 24 jahre alt geboren
1997 in mogadischu der hauptstadt von
somalia 6200 kilometer von würzburg
entfernt
es ist der sechste mai 2016 als
abdirahman nach deutschland kommt als
flüchtling erste station chemnitz dort
stellte er einen asylantrag erhält
subsidiären schutz ist also erst mal
legal in deutschland
2016 hält er sich in düsseldorf auf am
vierten september 2009 10
der damm nach würzburg lebt in einer
obdachlosenunterkunft vor einem halben
jahr dort dann seine erste gewalttat er
bedroht andere mit einem küchenmesser
ermittlungen wegen beleidigung und
bedrohung folgen der somalia kommt in
die psychiatrie für vier wochen
die ermittlungen werden eingestellt vor
wenigen tagen dann springt abdirahman j
in würzburg innenstadt vor ein auto
zwingt den fahrer ihnen die altstadt zu
bringen der vorfall endete unblutig
abderrahman kommt erneut in die
psychiatrie
diesmal nur einen tag lang es heißt kein
behandlungsbedarf kein behandlungsbedarf
hieß es herman warum lief der 24-jährige
noch draußen herum
das sind fragen die jetzt in der tat in
den nächsten tagen geklärt werden müssen
mir liegen diese informationen wie sie
dargestellt haben auch so vor
und daraus ergeben sich die fragen wer
hat ihn behandelt warum kann man zu
diesem ergebnis das er nicht
behandlungsbedürftig sei hätte man da
auch zu einer anderen beurteilung kommen
können
und das muss jetzt ganz sauber in den
nächsten tagen geklärt werden haben sie
noch keine weiteren hinweise was dort
möglicherweise die ärzte veranlasst
haben könnte nach nur einem einzigen tag
der mann hatte ja wie wir gerade gesehen
haben schon einmal menschen mit dem
messer bedroht dann gab es diesen
vorfall in der würzburger innenstadt wo
der mann einfach sich vor den auf ein
auto wirft einsteigt und den fahrer
zwingend ihn an eine andere stelle in
der würzburger stadt zu fahren das heißt
auch dass jan ein vorfall der nicht
alles andere als alltäglich ist auch
wieder eine bedrohung darstellt und dann
kommt der mann wieder einen tag in die
psychiatrie und dann heißt es alles
alles paletti soweit die fragen habe ich
mir in den letzten tagen ganz genauso
gestellt die habe ich auch an die
würzburger polizei gestellt mit der
bitte den jetzt nachzugehen und ich
hoffe dass zu spätestens morgen jetzt
gelegenheit besteht mit den behandeln
ärzten oder psychiatern darüber auch zu
sprechen und das zu klären
da muss dann auch manche dinge in der
natürlichkeit gibt es dann wieder die
schweigepflicht und ähnliches mehr
trotzdem wir wollen alles dafür tun dass
restlos aufzuklären
ich sei irgend etwas versäumt worden
hätte man das auch anders betrachten
können
aber ich bitte um verständnis im moment
liegen mir dazu leider noch überhaupt
keine weiteren informationen vor erneut
nun ist es ja klar nach nach der tat ist
man dann schlauer solche sätze hört man
ja auch immer wieder dann tauchen eben
die informationen auf die man dann wie
ein puzzle zusammensetzen anschließen
sagt wie wie konnte das sein und
gleichermaßen das löst natürlich genau
dieses gefühl in der bevölkerung aus es
gibt hinweise und dann gibt es sätze
wieder ist kein handlungsbedarf und
gleichzeitig kommt eben raus mensch der
mann der hat schon mehrfach menschen
bedroht irgendwie ist diese biografie im
sinne dieser tat dann logisch ja und vor
allem vor dem hintergrund der tatsache
dass wir in den letzten jahren eine ein
riesen anstieg gesehen haben bei
einzeltätern die oftmals auch psychische
probleme haben und das war vor 10 oder
15 jahren noch überhaupt nicht so da
ging man eigentlich in der wissenschaft
davon aus dass terroristen in der regel
psychologisch normal sind es gibt auch
viele studien die das beweisen
das hat sich aber in den letzten jahren
geändert und diese riesige ein anstieg
bei den einzeltätern symbol
rechtsextremen als auch islamistisch
ging einher mit einem anstieg von fällen
wo wir ganz starke zum teil
psychologische störungen haben herr
herrmann hat das beispiel genannt
münchen wir haben auch das beispiel
hamburg vor vier jahren gehabt wir
hatten auch letztes jahr in hanau zum
beispiel einen rechtsextremisten der
ganz offensichtlich auch psychische
störungen hat die erklären dass sich die
änderungen als behörden jetzt stärker
darauf einstellen wie erklären sich
diese veränderung die erklären sich
glaube ich durch zwei faktoren erstens
diese diese ganz komplizierten oder
komplett
von netzwerken organisierten
terroranschläge wie wir sie 2015 gesehen
haben die sind heute nicht mehr so
einfach durchzuführen als wenn sie das
versuchen würden dann würden ihnen die
sicherheitsbehörden wahrscheinlich auf
die spur kommen und deswegen haben sich
so recht einfach islamistisch die
kammerorganisation in der propaganda
drauf eingestellt diesen typus einsamen
wald wirklich zu propagieren ihn zu
verherrlichen und das sozusagen als
erstrebenswertes beispiel darzustellen
halten sie das für möglich
neumann dass dieser 24-jährige somalia
von isis angeworben wurde dass es dort
den versuch gab wirklich so eine tat zu
verüben organisiert also ich hab dafür
momentan keine anhaltspunkte wenn herr
herrmann da mehr weiß
dann wäre das interessant aber so
aufgrund dessen was wir bisher wissen
halte ich das eher für unwahrscheinlich
ich glaube auch dass der yes ja genau
aus dem grund weil es nicht mehr so
einfach ist in europa was sowas
durchzuführen in den letzten jahren auch
verstärkt dazu umgestiegen ist genau
diese inspirierten anschläge zu bewerben
also leute leuten zu sagen ihr müsst gar
nicht mitglied werden ihr müsst euch wo
ihr müsst uns gar nicht formale
anschließend ihr könnt auf eigene faust
irgendetwas tun und wir reklamieren das
dann für das hat auch in einigen fällen
erfolgreich
in dieser beschreibung würde der
24-jährige hereinfallen weil es ja nun
gerade sagte herrmann haben sie
derartige hinweise irgendwelche
anwerbeversuche aus dessen heimat
bislang haben wir darüber keinerlei
information keine derartigen hinweis ich
stimme da insgesamt in der einschätzung
der gesamtlage wie auch diese speziellen
situation sei aber völlig zu man muss
allerdings wir werden dem natürlich weil
das ja so cool ich nachgehen weil in der
hand die erfahrung bei dem anschlag vor
fünf jahren von dem ich eingangs schon
gesprochen habe mit diesem
islamistischen täter der wie er mit der
axt auf fahrgäste in einem
nahverkehrszug losgegangen ist
wir haben damals in der tat dann nach
einer weile weil wir da auch intensiv
handys extrem schwierig auszuwerten
waren nach einer weile mit spezialisten
des landeskriminalamts wirklich
sozusagen auseinander nehmen konnten die
verbindungen rekonstruieren konnten sind
wir dann nach einer weile dann
tatsächlich darauf gestoßen dass der
täter einen unmittelbaren kontakt mit
leuten im nahen osten hatte und zwar
nicht nur mit irgendwelchen sonstigen
freunden sondern der tat wie sich dann
herausgestellt auch mit jemand der dem
unmittelbare der islamistischen szene
angehört und er wohl von dort auch
möglicherweise anweisungen erhalten hat
das war das ergebnis aber erst nach
einer ganzen weile auch der akribisch
alle dinge auseinander genommen hat und
deshalb sage ich klar im moment haben
wir keine hinweise aber die das
landeskriminalamt wird dem trotzdem
natürlich genauestens nachgehen ob es
zum beispiel bei den beiden ihr
beschlagnahmten handys irgendwelche
hinweise auf solche kontakte gibt lassen
sie uns noch einmal über die biografie
dieses täters aus somalia sprechen über
den wir ja bruchstückhaft jetzt uns
langsam die information zusammensetzen
könnten können er ist 2015 nach
deutschland gekommen hermann ganz kurz
geantwortet ja oder nein war er zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt legal in deutschland
ganz eindeutig habe darüber gestern auch
nochmal mit dem bundesinnenminister
gesprochen der das auch mit dem
bundesamt für migration und flüchtlinge
besprochen hat bzw
von dort informieren hat lassen und das
bamf hat klar bestätigt ja der hat einen
positiven bescheid über den subsidiären
schutz bekommen
das heißt er war legal hier in
deutschland viele leuchtet das nicht ein
wie man seit 2015 in deutschland sein
kann
daneben 0 integriert sein kann zum
zeitpunkt mehrfach auffällig geworden
ist wenn auch nicht schwerst straffällig
dann in psychiatrische behandlung sich
begibt und das aber ganz normal es weil
man eben diesen subsidiären schutz
zugewiesen bekommen
hermann ja zunächst einmal in der tat
vor allen dingen psychiatrische probleme
heben eine asyl schutz natürlich nicht
auf das ganze hätte dann die situation
dass wir gegebenenfalls wenn wir jemand
dann für gefährlich halten in die andere
in unserem land auch in psychiatrische
einrichtungen zwangs unterbringen
müssten
das haben aber offen sich die fachleute
bis dato und nicht für notwendig
gehalten
aber klar ist ja ich wir sind dabei
jetzt dann erstmal diese unterlagen vom
dampf zu bekommen dann zusehen wie lief
diese ganze anerkennungsverfahren warum
man das subsidiären schutz bekommen usw
das kann ich zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt
nicht beurteilen bislang weiß ich nur
die fakten ja das dafür zuständige
bundesamt hat ihm subsidiären schutz
gegeben und der ist gültig bis er vom
baum wieder aufgehoben wird
herrmann habe neumann kurz vor der
sendung habe ich über diesen fall über
dieses messer massaker und jetzt die
ermittlungen auch mit bayerns
vize-ministerpräsident hubert aiwanger
gesprochen ich grüße sie waren ja sie
haben getwittert gestern direkt nach
dieser bluttat von würzburg genau
hinsehen um morde möglichst zu
verhindern hinweise in der karriere von
tätern beachten was haben sie damit
gemeint wir sehen leider gottes immer
wieder dass sich gewisse dinge
wiederholen dass menschen die eben seit
jahren in deutschland sind und nicht in
den arbeitsprozess integriert sind ja
irgendwann auffällig werden sich solche
auffälligkeiten wolfen und am ende
leider gottes dann teilweise bluttaten
geschehen also wir müssen hier wohl
genauer hinsehen so und sobald menschen
auffällig werden mit gewalt halten
sobald sie irgendwo psychologische
gutachten benötigen und so weiter dass
wir hier wirklich schauen und überlegen
ob wir solche leute nicht auch
losbekommen stichwort subsidiärer schutz
dieser begriff wurde ja quasi eingeführt
als so viele flüchtlinge damals nach 20
15 gekommen sind für die aber das
individuelle recht auf asyl nicht
anwendbar war dann sagte man eben ja wir
können die aber nicht mit dem schicken
sie kommen aus krisenregionen aus
kriegsgebieten so weit so gut aber wir
müssen seitens der bundesregierung auch
mehr tun also appel und die
bundesregierung dieses thema subsidiärer
schutz noch genauer beleuchten ob wir
hier wirklich wehrlos sind oder sorgen
müssten wir machen gezielt der
rückführungsabkommen und schauen dass
wir menschen auch in solche länder
wieder gezielter zurückbekommen wenn sie
bei uns auffällig werden
dieser mann dieser 24 jährige der war
schon in der psychiatrie der hat schon
eine zwangseinweisung der hat menschen
mit einem messer bedroht der erst vor
wenigen tagen noch mal vor ein auto
gesprungen hat noch mal einen drohung
ausgesprochen
und wie gesagt ist psychisch auffällig
geworden danach heißt es kein
behandlungsbedarf wie soll man das den
angehörigen der opfer vor allen dingen
erklären
also man kann das natürlich nicht mehr
wir brauchen hier mit sicherheit noch
mehr personal die bei solchen fällen
drüber schau dies ist natürlich auch
alle sehr personalaufwendig und diese
menschen haben trotzdem rechtsschutz
dass sie eben nicht so ohne weiteres
zwangseingewiesen werden können das ist
alles nicht so einfach da muss der staat
soll darüber gehen müssen urteile
gesprochen werden da müssen gutachten
ausgesprochen werden die müssen erst
fertig sein man kann das weder finger
schnitt machen aber an der stelle muss
gerecht stadt wohl noch justiert werden
wie würden sie aktuell sagen welche
terrorgefahr geht von diesen
flüchtlingen aus die in diesen jahren
215 216 zu uns gekommen sind
also ich würde auf alle fälle sagen wir
dürfen nicht pauschalisieren aber wir
dürfen auch nicht ignorieren und ich
glaube wir haben lange jahre jetzt
ignoriert und es ist immer dann die
haupt debatte wenn solche dinge
passieren das ist ja nicht in eine
rassismus ecke kommt also als auch nicht
drin aber wir müssen schon auch schauen
wo kommen denn diese täter her was
bewegt die ideen und es auf alle fälle
so dass hier zu viel passiert ist und
dass die normale öffentlichkeit diese
dinge nicht mehr mit trägt
seit dieser bluttat von würzburg es
auffällig gewesen wie verdruckst wie
vorsichtig man auch mit der
informationen umgegangen ist die der
bayerische innenminister sehr offen sehr
schnell auch öffentlich gemacht hat
nämlich dass es sich um einen
24-jährigen somalia handelt der als
flüchtling zu uns gekommen ist und
trotzdem fand sich diese information auf
vielen plattformen erst mal nicht wieder
und es war von einem amoklauf zunächst
die rede warum gehen wir weiterhin so
verdruckst mit solchen informationen mit
solchen taten um so viele und warum
nicht viel viel offener
ja weil das thema ausländerkriminalität
natürlich ein sehr brisantes thema ist
niemand will die dinge in den mund
nehmen um eben nicht in den vorwurf des
rassismus oder rechtsradikalismus zu
geraten
aber ich glaube dass wir damit genau das
gegenteil erreichen wenn wir die dinge
nicht beim namen nennen spielen wir
genau diesen kreisen den ball zu und die
sagen siehst du die wollen dinge
verheimlichen
also ich bin überzeugt wir sind gut
beraten in der breiten öffentlichkeit in
der politischen mitte
auch schonungslos zu sagen wir sind die
täter was bewegt die und was können wir
tun um solche taten künftig möglichst zu
verhindern endgültig verhindern werden
wie es mit können wir müssen auch ganz
offen sagen wir haben natürlich viele
kriminelle auch einheimische deutsche
aber das ist keine ausrede sondern ich
sage wenn wir schon mit den
einheimischen zu kämpfen haben dann
müssen wir uns nicht dinge antun die man
bei einer vielleicht etwas strikter in
asylpolitik vermeiden könnte
sie haben hunger zunächst die
flüchtlings geschichte auch angesprochen
dass 24 jährigen täters aus somalia der
genießt weiterhin subsidiären schutz
deswegen also rein rechtlich gesehen
der ist legal in deutschland diesen
schutz haben sie kritisiert würden sie
ihnen weiter einschränken wollen auf
alle fälle sind diese dinge die wir vor
fünf jahren ausgerufen haben in meinen
augen zu wenig tagesaktuell überprüft
die bundesregierung müsste also ständig
wieder drüber gehen müsste diese länder
beleuchten wo diese menschen herkommen
mit subsidiären schutz und müsste zu den
regierungen dort sorgen liebe leute
können wir
steinigungen finden ihr müsst
menschenrechte natürlich einhalten wir
helfen euch wirtschaftlich und so weiter
damit wir wenigstens kriminelle menschen
zurückbringen und nicht unseren leuten
immer sagen müssen ja die haben
subsidiären schutz damit müssen wir
leben
das ist kein weg entweder einweisung in
die psychiatrie oder eben frei rumlaufen
lassen oder abschieben ich glaube wir
müssen versuchen wirklich schwere fälle
wieder in die herkunftsländer zurück zu
bekommen
danke für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
ja das ist ja eine interessante frage
herr herrmann bayerischer innenminister
wir haben ihren kollegen gerade gehört
aus dem kabinett in
vize-ministerpräsident nubert aiwanger
der sagt da müssen wir noch mal ran an
diese regelung mit dem subsidiären
schutz müssen sie noch mal überprüfen
die kann nicht mehr aktuell seien die
wurde damals in der notsituation
eingeführt 215 2 16
da müssen wir jetzt ran wie sehen sie
ich glaube ich schon klug wenn man nach
der bundestagswahl sich in der
bundesregierung noch mal überlegt auch
auf europäischer ebene ob das auf dauer
so bleiben kann
es ist ja eine eu-richtlinie die diesen
subsidiären schutz eingeführt hat wer
ergibt sich nicht aus dem asylgrund
recht im grundgesetz und auch nicht aus
der europäischen flüchtlingskonvention
sondern das ist neu kreiert worden auf
europäischer ebene und ist damit noch
nicht schon relativ großzügig und das
muss überprüft werden vor allen dingen
in wie weit man das in bestimmten
situationen dann auch beenden kann und
mir liegt daher besonders am herzen das
gilt insgesamt in diesem flüchtlings
bereich dass wir jeden fall dass
personen die hier schwere straftaten
begehen oder die als gefährder
eingeschätzt werden auf jeden fall
wieder zurück aber ja schon maria außer
landes bringen kann
das war ja zeitweise war sie ausgesetzt
vor allen dingen in dem
corona anderthalb jahren aber noch mal
kurz bei dem subsidiären schutz bleiben
hier in diesem fall ging es um einen
mann 24 jahre alt als zumal ja der ist
seit sechs jahren bei uns der ist jetzt
mehrfach auffällig geworden hat menschen
bedroht bereits mit einem messer und ist
psychisch auffällig geworden und dann
stehen wir fassungslos vor dieser tat
und hubert aiwanger sagt auch das ist
der normalen bevölkerung doch nicht mehr
zu vermitteln dass der dann ganz legal
in deutschland ist das muss einfach noch
mal überdacht werden aber klar ist
natürlich auch erst müssen wir mal
erklären was war da eigentlich mit
diesen psychiatrischen untersuchungen
warum ist nach einerseits eingeliefert
worden und dann anschließend die
behandlung wieder beendet worden oder
erklärt worden sie seien nicht notwendig
das ist natürlich die grundlage
letztendlich der ganzen beurteilung und
dann muss man sich mit der frage
beschäftigen wenn wir es mit leuten zu
tun haben wo entsprechend wirklich
psychische schwere psychische probleme
festgestellt werden können wir die dann
auch wieder außer landes bringen
herr neumann ganz wichtige frage mich
würde interessieren ob sie in etwa
beziffern können vor allen dingen bei
jenen flüchtlingen wieso 25 10 216 2 17
auf dem höhepunkt der flüchtlingskrise
zu uns gekommen sind wie hoch würden sie
da die terrorgefahr ausgehen von denen
aktuell einschätzen
also die terrorgefahr lässt sich nicht
genau quantifizieren aber wir können
schon sagen dass die terrorgefahr in
deutschland trotz der schrecklichen
ereignisse jetzt in würzburg deutlich
geringer ist als vor sechs oder sieben
jahren und bei einer sache möchte ich
auch den hunger schon deutlich
widersprechen hat gesagt diese gefahr
wurde ignoriert das ist absolut nicht so
die sicherheitsbehörden polizei
verfassungsschutz in deutscher in ganz
deutschland haben sich sehr sehr
intensiv mit diesem problem der
flüchtlinge und potenziellen risiken
auseinandergesetzt und auch viele
mögliche attentate verhindert also
ignoriert wurde das absolut nicht denke
die haben auch erfolg gehabt denn wir
haben in deutschland trotz der
schrecklichen ereignisse an frei
eine geringere incidents von von
islamistischen terroranschlägen als in
vielen nachbarländern hermann
abschlussfrage einschießen professor
neumann ausdrücklich zu wenn ich das
sagen darf
das muss man wirklich sagen so schlimm
alle vorfälle auch bei uns sind aber das
vergleicht allein was in sich in unserem
nachbarland frankreich ereignet hat in
den letzten jahren dann muss man einfach
schon sagen dass wir einerseits entgegen
dem was immer er gesagt oder ist
frankreich sei so toll in der
integration dass dem ganz auf sich bei
weitem nicht so ist und das aber in der
tat auch jetzt nach anfänglichen
schwierigkeiten inzwischen unsere
sicherheitsbehörden auch in der
frühzeitigen er aller stiftungen
terrorgefahren
das verstehe ich empfinde es ein
bisschen vielleicht nicht ganz als den
richtigen moment das jetzt
herauszustellen wenngleich die statistik
ihnen ganz sicher recht gibt der
innenminister sie werden in den nächsten
tagen womöglich auf angehörige der opfer
treffen
es wird vermutlich trauergottesdienste
beisetzungen geben in würzburg werden
sie dann diesen angehörigen die augen
blicken können und ihnen die hand geben
können und sagen können wir haben alles
vorher getan dafür dass das dass so
etwas nicht passiert
ich habe einige angehörige
gerade heute nachmittag in würzburg
schon unmittelbar w10 stand in
unmittelbarer gemeinsam mit unseren
ministerpräsidenten gegenüber wir haben
heute eine große gedenkfeier im
würzburger dom gehabt mit katholische
evangelische kirche aber auch vertretern
der muslimischen gemeinde und auch der
jüdischen gemeinde in würzburg und wir
haben uns besonders mit der extrem
schwierigen situation der angehörigen
auseinandergesetzt
ja wir werden uns natürlich auch mit den
angehörigen und deren anliegen wir
wollen eben jetzt vor allen dingen
helfen wir wollen jetzt vor allen dingen
noch alles dafür tun dass die
schwerverletzten ja gut betreut werden
aber wir wollen dann und das haben wir
alle hin versprochen ihn bestmöglich
helfen beim weiteren leben
ich kann nur als innenminister ganz
generell sagen ja wir sind wirklich
bestrebt das menschenmögliche für die
sicherheit der menschen zu tun aber ich
muss auch immer wieder sagen ich kann
niemand 100 prozentige sicherheit
versprechen
dort wo wir probleme erkennen wo wir
defizite erkennen müssen wir sofort ran
gehen die zu beseitigen aber trotzdem
hundertprozentige sicherheit kann ich
leider so sind die menschen nicht
versprechen
danke herzlich für diese offenen worte
herr neumann hermann für diese wie fand
bewegen der sendung die begonnen hat mit
augenzeugen mit helfern mit helden aus
würzburg und in der wir diskutiert haben
gestritten haben über mögliche
konsequenzen aus dieser bluttat diesem
messer massaker von würzburg sie zu
hause habe es vielleicht gemerkt wir
haben diese sendung ausnahmsweise
aufgezeichnet sie haben es am
helllichten tag in würzburg gesehen und
wir werden uns weiter die nächsten
stunden die nächsten tage mit diesem
thema beschäftigen inwieweit wir lehren
ziehen müssen aus diesem massaker von
würzburg das uns so sehr bewegt und das
in der politik eine wichtige rolle
spielen wird ganz sicher auch in den
nächsten tagen
danke ihnen fürs zuschauen bis nächste
woche am sonntag die richtigen fragen
hier live
[Musik]